[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour bonjour à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat de
reportages et d'expertise sur Public
Sénat la promesse et dans le titre de
l'émission donner du sens à l'actualité
vous proposez des clés de compréhension
des mutations de nos sociétés 90 minutes
de débats avec l'actu pour commencer et
ce soir nous avons choisi de partir en
Iran pour comprendre ces manifestations
qui secouent le pays après la mort d'une
jeune femme arrêtée par la police des
mœurs révolte ou Révolution le régime
des mots là peut-il vaciller quel rôle
peut jouer la communauté internationale
alors que les négociations sur le
contrôle du programme nucléaire sont
dans l'impasse l'analyse de nos experts
dans deux minutes
et puis pour notre second débat je vous
propose de remonter le temps 30 ans en
arrière
oui nous voulons l'Europe mais debout
parce que monsieur le ministre c'est
debout qu'on écrit l'histoire
le 20 septembre 1992 malgré à cette
mobilisation de Philippe Seguin quelques
mois auparavant le oui l'emporte de
justesse lors du référendum sur le
traité de Maastricht c'est le point de
départ de la monnaie unique une étape
majeure de la construction européenne
mais c'est aussi la naissance d'une
fracture politique sur laquelle le
populisme et les extrêmes vont prospérer
relire le passé pour mieux comprendre
l'actualité c'est aussi l'objectif de
sens public rendez-vous dans 45 minutes
pour se débat mais d'abord l'histoire de
Masha Amini à laver 22 ans sa vie a
basculé lundi dernier quand des
policiers en civil l'arête pour port de
vêtements inappropriésman
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le lendemain jour de ses obsèques dans
la province du Kurdistan des femmes
retirent leur voile gestes interdit en
Iran
d'autres Scandes morts au dictateur
d'autres encore se filment ta visage
découvert en train de se couper les
cheveux
les manifestations gagnent tolérant et
ses universités où l'on réclame la fin
de la loi de 1979 sur le hijab
obligatoire et la suppression de la
police des mœurs des mouvements
fortement réprimés par la police
iranienne ces derniers jours pour tenter
de calmer la situation le président
conservateur et Brahim raïsi a demandé
l'ouverture d'une enquête afin de
déterminer les circonstances de la mort
de mars à mini
un nom déjà devenu un symbole
international comme ici à Berlin où des
femmes se coupent les cheveux en signe
de soutien aux Iraniens
voilà pour analyser la situation en Iran
j'accueille Agnès Levallois bonsoir
bienvenu vous êtes maîtresse de
recherche à la Fondation pour la
recherche stratégique vice-présidente de
l'Institut de Recherche et l'étude
Méditerranée Moyen-Orient manassi radis
bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi vous êtes
sociologue politique spécialiste de
l'Iran j'accueille Christian macarian
bonsoir bienvenue à vous éditorialiste
international au point et à Radio
Classique et Laetitia coupa éditoris
politique bonsoir Laetitia comment
analysez-vous ces manifestations Agnès
Levallois est-ce qu'on peut évaluer
peut-être c'est difficile j'imagine mais
l'ampleur de cette mobilisation alors
c'est très difficile d'avoir des
éléments précis quand même sur cette
mobilisation ce que l'on sait c'est que
effectivement cette le drame qui a vécu
cette jeune femme a suscité une vie
réaction mais ça n'est pas la première
réaction c'est à dire que on voit
régulièrement maintenant depuis des
années des mobilisations et lorsqu'il y
a un événement de cette importance en
fait on sent que tous les ingrédients
sont là pour qu'il y ait une réaction et
on sent que cette société iranienne ne
supporte de moins en moins ce système
politique cette cette écrasante
République islamique avec les
contraintes très fortes en particulier
pour les femmes mais pas que mais là ça
s'incarne dans le drame qui a vécu cette
jeune femme et donc on voit bien que
toutes les occasions sont bonnes si je
puis dire pour pouvoir exprimer parce
que mon expression se ras-le-bol de la
société iranienne des femmes mais on a
vu aussi des hommes manifester parce
qu'ils sont en soutiens aussi à ces
manifestations puisque je crois que en
particulier la jeune génération aussi ne
peut plus vivre sous cette le jour de
cette république islamique qui est là
depuis 1979 et je crois que la réaction
du pouvoir est aussi à la hauteur de
l'inquiétude que suscite ces
manifestations Dieu au pouvoir qui se
rend compte qu'effectivement la
légitimité dont il la disposé pendant
longtemps dont il dispose encore faut
pas croire que le régime va être balayé
mais en tout cas cette légitimité est
remise en question par de nombreux
iraniens et iranienne et ça je crois que
ça fait très peur ce régime parce que la
mobilisation lorsqu'on voit ses
manifestations dans la rue ça suscite
évidemment beaucoup beaucoup
d'inquiétudes pour revenir évidemment
sur la réponse de du régime manache
rallye est-ce que vous avez pu vous
aussi j'imagine essayer de glaner des
informations sur le nombre de villes
touchées on l'a vu dans le dans le sujet
ça part du Kurdistan qui est quand même
une région particulière dans dans cette
partie de la planète ça part du
Kurdistan ça ça fait un peu tâche
d'huile qu'est-ce que vous en savez sur
le nombre de villes touchées en tout cas
ce que je peux constater à travers les
témoignages des jeunes je trouve qu'on
est en face d'un événement et d'une
dimension très particulière d'une
nouvelle dimension dans le sens où dans
le décès dans le meurtre de Marso Amini
et une grande partie de la jeunesse
iranienne qui était jusqu'à là dans
l'indifférence qui était réfugiée dans
l'indifférence et faites partie de la
jeunesse se réveillait et vous savez
dans des situations difficiles dans des
sociétés difficiles quand les gens
n'arrivent pas à changer leur destin
politique ils se réfugient dans
l'indifférence je m'en foutiste c'est un
mécanisme de te défendre donc là vous
dites c'est différent alors des
mobilisations précédentes cet événement
réveillé cette partie importante de la
jeunesse qui s'était réfugiée dans
l'indifférence dans le jeu mon footiste
on voit qu'il se réveille il se sentent
en danger ils savent que ils vivent sous
un régime que même si ils ne sont pas
politisés même si ils se mêlent pas dans
les affaires de la vie politique en même
temps tout en restant à leur place ils
sont menacés c'est pourquoi depuis
quelques jours je n'arrête pas de
recevoir toute une série de messages de
la part des gens qui m'ont jamais écrit
par centaines sont en train de m'écrire
tu es toute jeune les filles entre 15 et
25 ans c'est la première fois elle
m'écrivent en disant que Madame chirali
nous sommes en danger nous n'osons pas
de le dire à nos parents mais nous
sommes en danger ils vont nous tuer
le téléphone de Christian Marcaille en
sonne c'est le moment où j'allais vous
poser une question ça tombe bien je vous
redonner la parole dans un instant et
évidemment on cherche et c'est compliqué
on l'a bien compris avec avec l'un et
l'autre
de
mesurer l'ampleur je disais révolte tout
révolution quand on j'ai ouvert cette
cette émission et de mon regard qui est
beaucoup moins
affûté que le vôtre sur ces questions je
pense au printemps arabe Christian
macarian est-ce qu'on peut comparer
parce que là il y a il y a eu une
étincelle aussi dans le printemps Arabia
eu un jeune homme qui s'est immolé par
le feu si on s'en souvient bien est-ce
que ça peut être comparable d'après vous
ou est-ce que finalement là c'était des
dictateurs
civils on est face à un régime religieux
est-ce que c'est comparable c'est une
bonne question j'avoue que je n'y avais
pas pensé mais
non je ne crois pas que ce soit
comparable d'abord parce qu'il y a déjà
eu des soubresauts antérieures notamment
lors des élections
potentiel truquées je me souviens les
manifestations les plus massives pour
armandineja dans l'occurrence il y a
déjà eu des soulèvements qui ont été
réprimés selon des techniques qui ont
été très bien décrites l'énergie du
régime qui ont un intérêt qui sont
financés qui n'ont pas de job s'ils ne
font pas ça constituent une véritable
colonne vertébrale répressive du régime
etc là tout est démentibulé c'est un
langage une attitude
lancée par des femmes qui à mon avis est
une véritable interpellation pour le
régime ce régime c'est réagir aux
révoltes politiques il sait réagir au
soulèvement de jeunesse par la
répression je ne suis pas sûr qu'il
sache réagir au mouvement de fond de
nature sociétale c'est-à-dire quelque
chose qui n'exprime pas
un point de vue politique
résolument engagé mais quelque quelque
chose qui exprime un désir de vivre et
d'affirmer des valeurs qui ne qui est au
fond un rappel à l'essentiel que le
régime a violé constamment depuis son
origine et je crois que c'est vraiment
quelque chose d'existentiel donc de ce
produit là je crois pas du tout que ce
soit comparable au mouvement arabe qui
visait fondamentalement à renverser un
tyran à instaurer une forme démocratique
ça n'a pas abouti mais là c'est quand
même quelque chose de beaucoup plus
profond c'est assez Pacifique pas
pacifiste et c'est vraiment fondé sur
des valeurs qui existent à l'intérieur
du peuple iranien
auquel on assiste en Iran alors je sais
pas tout à fait d'accord avec Christian
macarian je pense que ça montre aussi
l'énergie et la volonté de ces jeunes
sociétés des sociétés qui sont très
jeunes dans toute la région en Iran
comme dans les pays voisins qui sont des
pays arabes majorité d'entre eux et tous
ces différents mouvements et la
référence à 2011 éventuellement la
réplique de 2019 montre cette formidable
volonté de vivre de ces jeunes
populations et en ça ça peut se
rejoindre même si les sociétés sont
différentes même si les systèmes
politiques sont différents mais je crois
que le très commun à l'ensemble de ces
mouvements c'est cette volonté très
forte de ces jeunes de dire il y en a
assez de système politique qui nous
oppriment qui nous qui ont un
fonctionnement qui ne nous convient pas
et nous on veut entendre on veut faire
entendre notre voix alors évidemment que
ça va prendre des formes différentes que
l'Iran n'a rien à voir avec ce qui s'est
passé en Tunisie ou en Egypte mais je
crois qu'il faudrait pas oublier cette
ce formidable élan de ces sociétés j'ai
dû me dire que ce sont des sociétés qui
sont en mouvement et ce qui se passe en
Iran démontre cette ce mouvement de ces
femmes en particulier de ces jeunes
femmes qui ne veulent plus vivre dans
ces conditions de ces mouvements parce
que là quand on lit par exemple dans les
journaux on entend 500 personnes dans
cette ville 500 là quelques dizaines on
a du mal à mesurer l'ampleur du
phénomène voyez-vous si bien sûr il y a
plusieurs foyers de contestation je
comprends que c'est important mais si
c'est 10 % de la population 5 2
ne m'oblige jamais des millions de
personnes on l'a bien vu dans les autres
mouvements de contestation mais je vais
laisser parler ce que je pense qu'à la
beaucoup plus d'éléments que moi mais
les révolutions n'ont jamais été faites
avec des majorités mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est de voir que ce
mouvement pour l'instant est dans
plusieurs villes c'est-à-dire que ça
s'est passé à téran il y a des
mobilisations terrain mais dans le
Kurdistan doute et originaire de cette
jeune femme et donc le fait qu'il y ait
des mouvements dans les différentes
villes de térans maintenant fait voir
dans les campagnes est-ce que ça peut
atteindre la même façon ou la société
souvent plus conservatrice mais ça je
vous laisse parler je pense que vous
êtes sympa ce type de mouvement par le
nombre des gens on mesure par la
grandeur de la terreur qui règne sur une
société
et ces gens qui osent braver les
interdits et dans une société
militarisée terrorisée comme la société
iranienne le fait que les gens
osent sortir sans voile crier à balles
dictatures c'est énorme et ça montre que
derrière il y a un mouvement massif de
contestation des jours entiers les
Iraniens écrivent sur les réseaux
sociaux ils crient leur rage et là on
voit à travers
un événement à meurtre une étincelle de
ce genre tout d'un coup les gens osent
braver les interdits il faut parler de
ça qui est important
quand même de l'immense courage de ces
femmes et aussi de ces hommes qui
manifestent aujourd'hui que risque-t-il
au minimum la prison pas forcément
comment ça peut se passer alors j'ai
entendu dire en fait parce que je suis
les Iraniens à travers mes à travers mes
relations et dans les manifestations
cette fois-ci le régime ne tue pas
contrairement au novembre 2019 qu'il a
carrément ouvert les chars sur les gens
et ils ont le dire comme elle m'a alors
cette fois-ci les tirs ne sont pas
comparables avec le novembre 2019 par
contre ce qui est important c'est que il
procède à des arrestations massives par
exemple dans la région de Kurdistan hier
ils ont passé les gens une nuit
terrifiante parce que
les posterons les polices de la
République islamique les policiers de la
République islamique il arrêtait les
gens en masse il frappait à leur porte
et les arracher de leur lit de leur
chambre de leur maison et ils les
mettait dans les fourgonnettes et ils
les emmenaient en prison donc pas plus
tard qu'hier soir des milliers des gens
dans la région de Kurdistan ont été
arrêtés où ils sont partis personne ne
sait on n'est pas et les informations
qui arrivent de ce genre inquiète de
plus en plus parce que on sait pas quand
même quelle est la part de rumeurs
quelle est la part de peur et quelle est
de la part de la réalité mais en tout
cas on dit les rumeurs sont toujours
alimentés par une certaine réalité mais
c'est pour ça que les uns les autres
vous êtes plus dedans et je vous en
remercie Laetitia j'aurais quand je
prends on se penche pardon ensemble sur
la guerre des images c'est aussi ça vous
posez la question de l'efficacité de ces
séquences qu'on voit tourner un peu en
boucle sur les médias sociaux
bien sûr elle choque elles sont faites
pour cela elles sont faites pour alerter
l'opinion publique mondiale et surtout
occidentale pourquoi parce que c'est la
liberté des femmes qui est en question
les vidéos donc ou certaines iraniennes
ont la vue dans le sujet ce couple les
cheveux et brûle leur voix donc elles
sont devenues virales et ces séquences
pas je pense qu'on va aller voir on les
revoit en même temps pendant que vous
nous parlez elles ont été vu déjà des
millions de fois en France vous posez la
question de leur impact notamment en
Iran mais oui Thomas est-ce que ces
images sont vues en Iran est-ce qu'on
sont virales en Iran quel est le
retentissement de ces images en Iran et
dans les autres dictatures religieuses
est-ce que ces images par exemple
circulent en Afghanistan est-ce qu'elle
circule en Arabie Saoudite qui sont
aussi basées sur la négation de la
liberté de la femme et sur le postulat
de son infériorité parce que c'est quand
même l'hypothèse fondamentale dans ces
sociétés Dict
et religieuse évidemment il s'agit pas
de dire que ces images ne servent à rien
on le sait le poids des images montre et
donne un écho à une vous l'avez dit à
une révolution en tout cas une révolte
qui jusqu'à là était inédite mais encore
une fois est-ce que le pouvoir peut
tomber à cause des images est-ce que les
réseaux sociaux peuvent porter une
révolution vous avez fait bien sûr
référence aux révolution arabe oui ça a
marché mais après aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'il se passe
aujourd'hui ou en sommes-nous dans les
régimes de ces pays du Maghreb pour le
moment les manifestations en Iran sont
quand même réprimés par des tirs vous
l'avez dit aussi par des enlèvements par
des rafles et il y a surtout une
nouvelle loi qui est en train d'être
réfléchie par les hauts dignitaires de
l'Iran alors il s'agirait d'utiliser les
la reconnaissance faciale dans le métro
pour pour distinguer les femmes qui
seraient alors non voilées mais aussi
trop maquillée ou habillé trop court
donc vous voyez que pour l'instant le
pouvoir ne recule pas vraiment une chose
est sûre les femmes seules ne gagneront
pas ce combat il faut qu'elle soit
absolument accompagnées par les hommes
je suis d'accord il y a des hommes dans
les manifestations mais est-ce que vous
avez vu des hommes se couper les cheveux
moi je n'en ai pas vu voilà
le salut des femmes passera par la
solidarité des hommes est-ce que c'est
le cours de l'histoire de ces régimes
religieux de ces dictatures religieuses
personnes ne le sait Christian macarian
si on reviendra sur l'histoire de la
reconnaissance faciale parce que je
trouve que c'est assez intéressant mais
là on a on parle depuis le début de ce
débat d'un levier qui est majeur qui est
levier de la révolte d'une société jeune
et qui est en train de craquer c'est ce
que vous nous décrivez quels autres
leviers pourrait s'activer pour faire
vaciller ou tomber ce régime à des mots
là ouais je crois qu'il faut d'abord
pour répondre à votre question rappeler
dans quelle société on est et puisque
Agnès n'est pas tout à fait d'accord
avec moi je me permets de dire je le
suis pas non plus ce n'est pas la
Tunisie pas du tout l'Iran et il y a par
exemple beaucoup plus de femmes
professeurs de médecine en Iran qu'en
France et oui le régime a raté beaucoup
de choses mais pas nécessairement
l'alphabétisation ça c'est pas le point
le plus raté du du régime les femmes ont
des positions elles peuvent être
physiciens nucléaires justement ou
ingénieur
dans l'aviation oui donc qu'est-ce que
ça signifie ça signifie que c'est un
enjeu de pouvoir pour le pouvoir la
femme son statut son apparence sa
centralité est un enjeu de pouvoir c'est
un pouvoir religieux certes mais c'est
aussi la femme le symbole de la
modernité de l'ouverture de la
transformation
qui est derrière de l'idée démocratique
donc
si les femmes veulent protester
autrement que sous forme de
manifestations contenu de leur présence
et de leur force dans la société il y a
d'autres moyens d'agir peut y avoir des
formes de grève de refus d'obtent
tempéré il peut y avoir beaucoup de
choses je rappelle aussi que la police
religieuse qui s'occupe des femmes est
constituée de femmes il faut aussi tout
dire qui sont vêtus du tchador intégral
donc il y a des réalités qui sont très
complexes et très propres à la société
iranienne à mon avis j'aurais parlé de
la petite cette histoire de
reconnaissance faciale quelles infos
vous avez madame chirali est-ce que elle
est déjà à l'oeuvre peut-être la
capitale Téhéran est-ce que il maîtrise
la pardon ma question est peut-être un
peu est-ce qu'il y a la technologie
maîtrisée parce que je disais dans un
article que certes il y a des caméras
mais peut-être que on sait pas analyser
les images suffisamment précisément
malheureusement ils savent parfaitement
analysé parce que il procède des
arrestations massives après coup une
fois que les manifestations sont
terminées et il arrête les gens qui
étaient dans les filles les jeunes
filles qui étaient pas fermement moins
voilé il les arrête après coup donc
malheureusement il maîtrise parfaitement
bien en tout cas assez bien pour
procéder à des artistes arrestations et
l'une des questions posées Laetitia
c'était est-ce que ces vidéos que nous
on voit comment circulent-elles en Iran
parce que j'imagine que ceux qui les
publient des risques aussi tout à fait
alors il faut quand même savoir que nous
sommes en train de parler d'un pays où
l'espace public et hermétiquement fermé
donc depuis quelques années les Iraniens
ont créé un espace public parallèle sur
les réseaux sociaux quand vous étiranien
et que vous n'êtes pas sur Instagram
vous n'êtes pas sur Twitter si vous
n'êtes pas sur Facebook vous n'êtes pas
vous faites pas partie de la communauté
des gens donc
[Musique]
la tenue sociale et respectée et ce qui
est intéressant de voir c'est que il y a
quelques années en fait la pression
était beaucoup moins de sur les sur les
femmes en particulier moi je me suis
alors de mon dernier séjour en Iran
avant le covid en fait il y avait pas du
tout cette pression qui a aujourd'hui et
on voit bien qu'avec le nouveau
président iranien qui a été élu qui
était vraiment un conservateur on voit
qu'il y a eu une reprise en main de la
part de la société par les forces
politiques puisqu'il y avait quand même
eu un relâchement et moi je me suis une
fois j'étais dans la rue où j'avais
juste le foulard sur la tête puisque
c'était obligatoire et j'ai croisé une
jeune iranienne qui m'a fait un petit
signe pour me dire mais il faut le
mettre un peu plus loin puisque elle
elle prenait des libertés et elles
étaient un peu énervées de voir que les
occidentales qui avaient peur justement
des contraintes mettez le voile beaucoup
trop de façon beaucoup trop stricte par
rapport à elle qui prenait des libertés
au nombre de centimètres de cheveux qui
apparaissent quoi
c'est qu'on sentait qu'il y avait
justement un relâchement de la part de
cette police des mœurs moi j'en ai dans
la rue je me suis quand même beaucoup
promené à thérent j'en avais pas vu ce
qui ne veut pas n'existait pas et
qu'elle ne faisait pas leurs
informations civile
mais ceci dit ce sont aussi beaucoup des
femmes effectivement qui vont contrôler
et qui elles vont elles pour le coup
elles sont vraiment habillées tenues
traditionnelles maximales si je puis
dire elles prennent pas du tout de
liberté avec la tenue comme les
Iraniennes peuvent le faire et ce qui
m'a frappé la danse et les dernières les
événements auxquels on insiste c'est
qu'on se rencontre qu'effectivement il y
a une recrudescence de la part de de
contrôle de la société par ses forces de
police qui effectivement sont là pour
vérifier que cette jeune femme n'avait
pas mis son voile exactement comme il
fallait alors qu'il y a quelques années
c'était j'allais dire monnaie courante
dans les rues de Téhéran ces libertés
qui étaient prisées donc on voit bien
qu'il y a eu un durcissement de la part
de du système politique et ça ça nous
amène vraiment à la question politique
aujourd'hui avec la présence de ce
président qui est un vraiment un ultra
conservateur et qui même si leur donner
une enquête pour essayer de comprendre
d'où venait quand il a vu la réaction
justement face à la à la mort de les
femmes on sent effectivement que ce
pouvoir se demande comment réagir face à
cette mobilisation
je trouve qu'il a l'air d'un peu
d'hésiter bon il réprime ça c'est
évident parce que c'est la seule chose
qui se fait faire
habituels je crois qu'il sait que si il
laisse s'il laisse un peu les choses
avancées à terme c'est ça c'est sa
légitimité qui sera complètement moi je
crois que c'est vraiment ça la question
parce que je crois que c'est ce qui
viendra dans un cours instant c'est une
bonne question on l'a prévu mais on va y
revenir dans un très court instant je
vous laisserai la poser d'ailleurs mais
je vous propose d'autres images qui me
semblent intéressantes sur la la
puisqu'on essaye d'évaluer l'ampleur de
cette révolte l'un de ces policiers en
civil poursuivi frappé par la foule
c'est une vidéo qui a été publiée par un
opposant iranien régime démola il est
exilé en France s'appelle hafsin à la
vie elles sont selon lui datées d'hier
soir cette scène elle se déroule dans le
nord du pays dans la ville de rasch
pardon pour la prononciation donc
je pense que vous le voyez bien c'est
vraiment il y a une foule qui qui court
après un homme et qui le moleste le
frappe les uns après les autres sont des
hommes qui lui court après
majoritairement
acheter un lit affirme que des scènes
identiques ont lieu dans d'autres villes
du pays Massir Ali là c'est encore un
degré supplémentaire c'est
oser s'attaquer à
représentants du pouvoir assez policiers
en civil est-ce que c'est un degré
supplémentaire pour vous ou pas
peut-être que ça a déjà eu lieu c'est la
force de solidarité c'est que à partir
du moment où les gens les Iraniens
arrivent à braver les interdits à sortir
à manifester malgré cet immense terreur
qui règne sur les rangs ils prennent
confiance en eux et c'est le ce que vous
avez vu dans ces images je les ai reçus
hier moi aussi c'est une ça montre que
quand un peuple prend confiance dans sa
volonté et dans sa force personne ne
peut lui résister c'est une mais ma
question c'était est-ce que on a déjà
assisté à des scènes comme celle-là lors
d'autres
révoltent ou mouvements populaires en
Iran je n'avais pas vu c'est la première
fois
c'est très important c'est très
important ça veut dire que de plus en
plus les Iraniens sont en train de
prendre confiance en leur action en leur
capacité d'agir c'est quelque chose qui
est quand même très important
laetitia a donc la question vous vous
posez parce que si le pouvoir tombe
imaginons que cette révolte et que le
pouvoir ne sait pas y répondre et
finalement tombe le dans les problèmes
de de révolution arabe justement ce qui
s'est passé c'est qui après ceux qui
tombent qui peuvent reprendre le pouvoir
et ceux-là il y a une opposition par
exemple
en ce moment ce pays il y a un tel chaos
dans ce pays que vraiment il y a un
absence total total d'un pouvoir
politique qui arrive à gouverner il est
rain tel chaos que les Iraniens ne se
posent pas la question parce que le
chaos est déjà là et vous pensez que
dans un pays avec 85 millions
d'habitants avec 10 millions iraniens à
l'étranger hautement cultivés avec des
millions hautement cultivés à
l'intérieur du pays vous pensez que ils
sont incapables de organiser déjà et je
vais poser la question pardon nous
interrompre peut-être Christian Mata
macariens je suis sûr que vous pouvez
nous en parler aussi Agnès Valo mais
est-ce qu'il y a encore parce que là on
parle de de d'une éruption populaire bon
qu'on peine encore à mesurer c'est
peut-être un peu trop tôt mais est-ce
qu'il y a encore une opposition
constituée qui s'exprime par des canaux
on va dire l'ego public en termes
d'opposition n'est pas forcément
appropriée contestation sans doute mais
il faut aussi contestation intérieure
oui on vient de voir des images qui qui
sont très très illustratives mais il y a
aussi ce qui se passe à l'étranger donc
pour ce qui est d'une opposition
constituée il y a le groupe à l'étranger
bon
d'importance diverses et d'ailleurs de
qualité et de réputation diverses aussi
à Paris par exemple donc il y a
différents cercles mais fondamentalement
moi je ne sais qu'une chose en tant que
journaliste il y a dix jours à peine si
nous avions dit sur le plateau de cette
émission qu'une la mort d'une femme
causée par une police religieuse va
suffire à enflammer tout le pays et que
dans de très nombreuses villes
spontanément des femmes puissent suivies
par des hommes vont se rebeller et
envoyer des slogans tout à fait
contraire à ce qui se passe et mettre le
pouvoir en cause tout le monde aurait
dit non c'est impossible or c'est ce qui
est en train de se passer donc je
propose qu'on soit modeste face aux
événements et qu'on dise qu'on fasse
confiance au peuples iraniens qu'on dise
qu'on peut encore se tromper sur le
degré de pourrissement de ce régime
parce qu'il y a un climat social
économique abominable en Iran il y a des
gens qui vraiment ont beaucoup de mal à
boucler les fins de moi qui mangent pas
à leurs faim la crise économique est
effroyable les effets de la pandémie on
ne les connaît pas tellement il y a du
mensonge sur le nombre réel des victimes
etc c'est un pays qui est littéralement
à la ramasse et qui en plus dans la
crise de l'Ukraine subit lui aussi les
effets et qui se trouvent quand même en
liaison assez étroite avec la Russie il
y a encore beaucoup de développement
possible qui vont à mon avis dans le
sens et je dirais une dernière chose
dans un sens qui est très négatif pour
le pouvoir et un dernier point c'est que
ce pouvoir n'a pas de savoir faire face
à une société qui n'est pas mue
justement par des groupes politiques
faciles à identifier à réprimer et là si
vous avez contestation polymorphe mais
profonde ce pouvoir n'a pas le
savoir-faire c'est ce que nous disait
Agnès tout à l'heure sur une opposition
même larvée même clandestine peut-être
là aussi que c'est difficile de répondre
à cette question mais il y a des
associations en Iran bien sûr qu'il y a
des oppositions il y a des opposants il
y a des personnes qui prennent des
risques qui ont pris des risques il y a
eu la fameuse révolution
en quelle année maintenant j'ai un trou
de mémoire où il y avait toute cette
opposition qui est qui avait fortement
manifesté en Iran lors des élections
donc il y a une opposition qui existe il
y a une défense politique qui sont
présentes dans ce pays donc je crois que
la question de la relève n'est pas la
question pertinente à ce stade c'est ce
que je veux dire par là c'est que c'est
évident que dans un pays comme l'Iran
avec des beaucoup de d'Iraniens formés
avec des compétences indéniables et on
l'a vu lors de toutes ces dernières
années qui sont passées il y a des
personnes qui sont compétentes la grande
difficulté c'est que c'est un pays qui
s'écoulement délitée le système mythique
tant ce qu'il est une situation
économique de par les sanctions qui sont
imposées à ce pays maintenant depuis des
années des années vous avez tout un
tissu économique qui est mis à mal parce
que aucun investissement ne peut être
fait pour mettre en état pour maintenir
en état les infrastructures permettant
au pays de se développer donc vous avez
un délitement de du tissu économique
industriel considérable et alors que le
pied est très riche parce qu'il a du
pétrole alors sa manière il profite
aujourd'hui la crise de la crise
ukrainienne puisque le l'Iran a du
pétrole et du gaz et que donc
bien sûr il y a tout un système de il y
a des réseaux évidemment comme on a
besoin aujourd'hui le monde a besoin de
pétrole on peut fermer les yeux sur
certaines pratiques pour obtenir de ce
pétrole et que donc c'est une occasion
aujourd'hui pour l'Iran d'avoir un peu
plus d'argent mais c'est vrai que ce
qu'il faut bien comprendre me
semble-t-il c'est l'état vraiment de
déliquescence de la société iranienne en
raison de ses sanctions économiques qui
font qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup d'Iraniens
n'ont plus rien à perdre aussi et que
donc dans cette sensibilisation ce que
l'on sent aussi c'est que trop c'est
trop c'est-à-dire que beaucoup
d'Iraniens ne mangent plus de viande
depuis maintenant des mois et des mois
parce que ça coûte une fortune que les
ressources économiques ne sont plus là
même s'il y a une légère embellie comme
je viens de le dire grâce à la crise en
Ukraine et le fait que l'Iran peut
exporter un peu plus de pétrole mais les
sanctions sont quand même ravageuses une
partie de la population iranienne
souhaiterait que le fameux accord soit
nucléaire soit signé pour qu'une partie
des sanctions soit levée et que de
l'argent Vienne et apportent une
amélioration dans la vie du quotidien
même si une autre partie ne veut pas en
entendre parler parce que les dures
estiment que on va il faut tenir tête
aux Américains donc ce qui je pense
qu'il est important aussi dans ce
mouvement de prendre en compte ces
différentes dimensions qui donnent mieux
aussi à comprendre ce qui se joue à
savoir une société qui est exemple qui
est épuisée et qui a les plus grandes
difficultés à joindre les deux bouts et
donc il y a un moment aussi quand vous
sentez que vous n'avez plus rien mais
plus rien à perdre et bien vous et c'est
ça aussi je pense qu'il peut faire peur
à ce régime de se rendre compte que
aujourd'hui une partie des Iraniens se
disent bon on y va et on verra bien ce
qui va se passer alors le rôle de la
communauté internationale voilà ce dont
on va parler et notamment on va parler
des négociations sur le programme
nucléaire iranien mais je voudrais
commencer Laetitia avec vous peut-être
pour dire un mot des réactions des des
personnalités femmes et hommes
politiques français à la mort de cette
jeune femme on va dire qu'elles sont
modérées c'est ça service minimum fin de
l'édito quelques tweets il y a elle
brune pivée par exemple la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale Valérie Pécresse
Olivier fort Bruno Retailleau et puis il
y a cette phrase cliché qui revient qui
dit le combat des femmes iraniennes et
le nôtre c'est faux ça n'a rien à voir
là quand un homme ou une femme politique
prononce cette phrase écrit cette phrase
il s'adresse où elle s'adresse surtout à
l'opinion publique
occidentale pour nous conforter nos
femmes dans nos libertés acquises
il y a aussi des opportunistes et oui il
y a aussi les opportunistes qui n'ont
pas peur un peur de rien comme Bruno
Retailleau qui lui dans son tweet en
profite carrément pour mettre un tacle
au néo-féministe françaises qui se
tromperait de combat je le cite pendant
que les néo féministes d'ici dissertent
sur le sexe des barbecues les vrais
féministes d'aujourd'hui luttent en Iran
au péril de leur vie au minimum Thomas
c'est hors sujet et c'est surtout
indécent et après après les mots après
les condamnations souvent molles je vous
ai même pas passé le tweet du ministère
des Affaires étrangères qui vraiment
étaient bon on va dire un service
minimum vraiment obligatoire je pense
par les faits quels sont les actes après
les mocassons les conséquences comment
la France peut-elle interférer dans
l'histoire de l'Iran surtout vous l'avez
dit Madame quand on a besoin de ce pays
sur la scène géopolitique alors
effectivement le le gaz iranien il
serait ou le pétrole il serait bien
utile à en ce moment livraison elle
passe peut-être par des canaux détournés
on va on va parler de ça on va parler
surtout de de l'arrêt du programme
nucléaire iranien des négociations qui
sont en cours avec Tam traduis qui doit
être juste derrière bonsoir Tam
bienvenue sur ce plateau elles en sont
où aujourd'hui c'est négociations alors
pour commencer on va faire un petit
retour en arrière en 2015 l'accord sur
le nucléaire iranien et conclut il doit
empêcher Téhéran de se doter de l'arme
atomique en échange de la levée de
sanction qui asphyxie l'économie
iranienne trois ans plus tard 2018 et
bien l'accord il est torpillé par Donald
Trump depuis et bien le président des
États-Unis a changé les négociations
repris en 2021 et cet été les
négociateurs avaient réussi à lever
plusieurs points de blocage ce qui
laissait voir un peu de lumière au bout
du tunnel et patatras dans une
déclaration conjointe le 10 septembre la
France le Royaume-Uni l'Allemagne
déplore je cite la poursuite de
l'escalade nucléaire de l'Iran et son
absence de coopération avec à l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie atomique et
une attitude qui je cite encore met en
péril les perspectives de rétablir
l'accord sur le nucléaire iranien dans
la foulée l'Iran dénonce un acte non
constructif et regrettable deux jours
plus tard le chancelier allemand Olaf
Scholtz ne se fait plus beaucoup
d'illusions
la corne arrivera certainement pas dans
un prochain avenir malgré les apparences
à un moment donné
nous restons patients nous restons aussi
clair il faut empêcher l'Iran de se
doter de l'arme nucléaire ce qui sera un
danger pour toute la région et pour de
nombreuses régions au-delà
Emmanuel Macron a rencontré en cette fin
d'après-midi en marge de l'Assemblée
nationale des Nations Unies le président
iranien Ibrahim qu'est-ce qu'on peut
attendre d'un tel entretien écoutez si
on écoute la ministre de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères on n'attend pas
grand chose en tout cas sur le dossier
du nucléaire iranien hier Catherine
Colonna a donné une conférence de presse
à New York et elle s'est pas montrée
très optimiste on écoute
la fenêtre d'opportunité qui était déjà
encore faiblement ouverte à la fin du
mois d'août
me semble près de se refermer et nous ne
cessons de dire chacun d'entre nous à
titre national ou à plusieurs vous
l'avez vu encore la semaine dernière
que il n'y aura pas de meilleures offres
sur la table pour l'Iran
et qui lui appartient
qui lui appartient de prendre une
décision voilà malgré les négociations
le programme nucléaire iranien accélère
selon un rapport de la IEA datant du
mois de mai la République islamique a
accumulé un stock d'uranium enrichi qui
dépasse de plus de 18 fois la limite qui
était autorisée par l'accord de 2015 ce
qui pour les Européens va je cite encore
bien au-delà de toute justification
civile plausible
macarian tout ça se passe dans un
contexte de rapprochement avec la Chine
et la Russie et bien on assiste
aujourd'hui au retour à une logique de
bloc avec d'un les Occidentaux de
l'autre un axe Chine Russie auquel se
rattache aujourd'hui l'Iran l'Iran qui
craint un peu moins les sanctions
américaines en s'appuyant sur Moscou et
Pékin et puis il y a aussi une donne du
côté des États-Unis où la situation est
compliquée pour des raisons de politique
intérieure les républicains sont
farouchements opposés à un accord avec
l'Iran par exemple or il paraît
aujourd'hui très hautement improbable de
conclure un accord avant les élections
de mi-mandat c'est les élections du 8
novembre prochain en cas de victoire des
républicains on voit encore moins
comment s'attaquant pourrait être conclu
mais on en est pas encore là merci Tom
pour toutes ces explications Christian
maccarian est-ce que vous diriez l'Iran
est dans une position de force liée au
contexte international sur cet accord
sur le nucléaire non non parce que il a
pour allier quand même Vladimir enfin
alliés c'est pas le terme exact comme
pays partenaire la Russie qui est le
moins qu'on puisse dire n'est pas en
différentes formes la Russie devait
devenir Poutine il a pour fournisseur la
Chine qui est un pays extrêmement
prudent la Chine qui est très proche de
l'Iran l'économie iranienne vient grande
partie survie grâce à la Chine c'est
tout à fait essentiel mais c'est un pays
qui reste complètement isolé l'effet des
sanctions et quand même ravageur comme
la décrit Agnès Levallois tout à l'heure
ça continue à s'exercer donc il y a
qu'ici il compense que les sanctions ça
sert à rien du tout je veux dire ici en
Occident croyez moi que je souhaite pas
à aucun pays
occidental de subir des sanctions du
type de sel qui sont imposées à l'Iran
qui portent même sur les médicaments de
base donc un nouveau-né est menacé par
ces sanctions là par exemple ça prend
une allure très très concrète non l'Iran
n'est pas du tout dans le camp des
vainqueurs de surcroît il y a pas deux
camps dans le monde à l'heure actuelle
ce que l'assemblée
de l'ONU va démontrer c'est qu'il y en a
trois il y a ceux qui sont
éventuellement pour soutenir la Russie
ça fait 7 pays c'est vraiment très très
peu sur 193 il y a ceux qui sont dans le
camp occidental pour sanctionner la
Russie etc et pour sanctionner aussi
l'Iran et puis il y a tous ceux qui sont
au milieu et qui n'ont pas envie d'être
entraînés dans cette confrontation et là
à ce titre là l'Iran est noyé dans la
masse regardez par exemple le poids d'un
pays comme l'Inde
l'Iran est très embarrassé face à un
pays comme l'Inde c'est un vrai vrai
concurrent ce qui fait que oui peut-être
l'Iran écoulera un peu mieux son pétrole
mais de toute façon l'Iran est en
sous-capacité de raffinage l'Iran est un
pays qui est un paradoxe incroyable à
cause justement du fait que soit un pays
paria mis au banc du reste de la planète
c'est un pays qui n'a pas eu le temps de
renforcer ses capacités de raffinage
il exporte du brut et ça le met en état
de dépendance par exemple vis-à-vis d'un
pays auquel il vend du pétrole comme
l'Inde sur sur la plus-value que peut
représenter ces ventes de pétrole l'Iran
est un pays qui est dans une posture
extrêmement difficile ça expliquer là
pourquoi
il se crispe d'autant plus sur la
question nucléaire alors justement Agnès
Levallois vous l'avez un peu décrit tout
à l'heure mais je pense que c'est
passionnant de de détailler ça c'est à
dire qu'il y a des au sein même du
pouvoir iranien certains qui
militeraient pour pour signer cet accord
sur le nucléaire pour donner un peu
d'appel d'air on l'a compris économique
au pays oui certains considèrent qu'il
faudrait absolument signer cet accord
puisque ça permettrait même si les
élections de mitter aux États-Unis vont
avoir une risque d'avoir une incidence
sur cet accord de se dire on aura
peut-être quand même quelques mois et
pendant lesquelles on peut engranger un
peu de devises et permet justement de
donner un peu à cette économie d'autres
en revanche disent mais on n'a aucun
intérêt et c'est la fenêtre de tir est
tellement étroite qu'on a aucun intérêt
finalement pardon nous interrompre les
révoltes auxquelles on assiste pourrait
pousser ce camp-là a avancer ses pieds
en disant bah justement c'est le moment
de signer l'accord pour se donner un peu
d'air économique et calmer la foule sauf
que ça peut aussi vite que ça peut-être
ce qu'on voit bien c'est que le
président actuel qui est quand même
plutôt un conservateur et qui lui n'est
pas du tout en faveur d'un dialogue avec
les avec les Américains ou en tout cas
cet accord soit il serait dit un peu
plus soit effectivement il comprend
qu'il a plutôt intérêt à essayer
d'ouvrir un petit peu le jeu d'un point
de vue stratégique donc je pense que les
négociations qui ont lieu en ce moment
les discussions en tous les cas New York
peuvent peut-être permettre de faire
bouger les lignes et je pense que si
effectivement le communiqué du Quai
d'Orsay était aussi soft passion sur ce
qui se passe en Iran c'est peut-être
évidemment pour préserver la discussion
qui doit avoir lieu à New York entre le
président Macron et son homologue
iranien un dernier mot de conclusion il
nous reste une minute dans ce
est-ce que le peuple iranien attend
quelque chose d'un président français ou
d'une ou d'une Union européenne
dans un contexte comme celui-là
excellente question en effet en effet
parce que ils ont compris quand il y a
les regards des Occidentaux rivés sur la
société iranienne sur la violence de
l'État envers la société et l'État n'ose
pas avancer dans ces exactions n'ose pas
réprimer les Iraniens le n'avons pas
oublié 2019 vraiment un nombre
inestimable des Iraniens ont péri sous
les chars sur les tirs et après c'était
une pression de la part des Iraniens qui
étaient à l'étranger sur les
gouvernements occidentaux et les
Occidentaux ont réagi depuis on voit que
à chaque fois les Iraniens contestent
ils sortent l'état n'osent pas les tuer
n'osent pas faire le même massacre
pourquoi parce les regards des
Occidentaux surtout les journalistes
surtout la société civile des pays
occidentaux et rivés sur l'Iran c'est
pourquoi les Iraniens comptent
énormément sur les médias occidentaux
sur les journalistes occidentaux et ils
s'oublier hier
ecoutez-nous ils sont en train de nous
tuer ne nous laissez pas mourir sans
attendre donc c'est très important ce
que les Occidentaux surtout les médias
font par rapport à dire merci beaucoup
merci à tous les trois d'avoir participé
à ce débat bientôt dans le sens